welcome ladies and gentlemen to a
special podcast joining us is Ben
Shapiro what's going on dude do you want
to introduce yourself not that I think
you need to but
um sure uh so I'm editor emeritus of the
daily wire co-founder of the daily wire
host of the Ben Shapiro show uh you know
some some books that that'll do it right
on right on so we're also hanging out
with Sheamus Coughlin of Freedom Tunes
yes this is actually my first time here
with Ben Shapiro instead of just doing
his voice
right on and we got Ian Crossland hi
everyone what up oh so anyway uh let's
just we'll just jump in we we've not
done anything like this before but uh
considering we're out here in Nashville
we've got you know you're here and able
to make time for us as well as we had
Jonathan Isaac so we're all excited and
I'm just going to jump into this viral
uh Twitter Trend we have the story from
Newsweek Ben Shapiro called Bozo by
student during anti-transgender event
I just love how they frame stories as if
that was the takeaway from the event I
mean well so a couple of things one it's
not a news event when someone calls me a
name I mean that that's like most of my
life actually so including from my
children so like being called a bad name
is not actually a news event but what
would actually happen here is if you
watch the entire clip there's a kid who
got up there and he started
by you know suggesting that who's a
mathematician and a physicist double
major and he won all these Awards and I
congratulated him on that and then he
proceeded to spew a bunch of nonsense
and then when he was rebutted on his
nonsense like he actually accused me of
using the dsm-4 as opposed to the DSM-5
which wasn't true he suggested that I
use the language gender identity
disorder as opposed to gender dysphoria
that wasn't true I corrected him uh and
uh and when he had sort of run out of
arguments then he called me a bozo and
then made a reference to that famous
video from about a year and a half ago
where I where I read the lyrics to uh
cardi B's which is it is it thank you I
mean if you actually watch the 15-minute
version they've only played like the two
minute version I will say I'm quite
proud of the 15 minute full takedown uh
and breakdown of lap it slapped
significantly harder than her original
version uh and um and frankly it's it's
pretty funny it's one of the funniest
things I've ever done on the show uh and
so that's sort of become a meme online
so he uh he started saying this stuff he
started insulting my wife and and I said
back to him I don't really feel like I
need to have my masculinity challenge by
somebody like I have three kids it's
like I I really like really I don't need
to talk about my sex life with you uh
and um and then the takeaway from this
according to the media was that somebody
called me a bozo now the reason that
happened is that I've noticed that
Twitter plays this game
uh I tried once about probably once
every three weeks on Twitter so yeah it
really charts out so the day after the
Twitter Trend I'm kind of happy because
like three weeks until I tried again but
the way that it typically works is that
there will be a good story that starts
to get some traction about me on Twitter
and it won't Trend and then within 24
hours Twitter will be trending me about
something that is either unrelated or
recasting the story so yesterday or
earlier last week when this uh when this
video came out at the beginning it
already had a couple of million views
and it was the full version it was like
a two two minute version that had a
couple million views I think now it has
you know four million views online and a
lot of people are talking about it and
then they waited for about 24 hours for
somebody to come out with like a 10
second version of the video with just
this kid insulting me and then they
trended it with that video because the
idea is that the story can never be that
we had this exchange and this kid came
off pretty badly and if you watch the
entire exchange honestly I feel bad for
me came off pretty badly
um here's the craziest thing about it
are we concerned with people being
convinced by someone just insulting you
and not really making any substantive
arguments I mean that that really is the
question I mean that wasn't the only
time that happened during the event by
the way I mean there was a point earlier
in the event where it was disrupted by a
guy up in the rafter shouting [ __ ] you
at me and I and I immediately responded
by saying [ __ ] you was not an argument
right and which it isn't and also number
two no thank you right that was those
are the things I said back to him um and
um you know that that stuff that sort of
stuff is not a headline they had to
recraft the entire media apparently I
had to recraft the headline so the big
issue was that somebody said something
nasty to me now here's the way that
works if I had something to ask you to
the student right I'm invariably pretty
polite in these exchanges if I had
something said something really nasty
back to the student about his sex life
or something then it would have been a
major story about what a jackass I am
but somebody says something like that to
me and they did what a hero what what a
stud this kid okay you know what if
that's the way the game is played I
guess that's the way the game is played
whatever yeah exactly when I saw this
headline my first thought was of course
they concentrate on the fact that this
kid called you a bozo rather than the
fact that he may depraved sexual remarks
and insults about yourself and your wife
if the reverse had happened if some
conservative audience member had shouted
at a left-wing pundit this really
disgusting perverted stuff about their
sex life with their spouse that would
absolutely be the headline it would be
hearing about how harassment is such a
serious problem on the right side of
politics you know what I see is
interesting here you know I tweeted
about it
the dude made no argument as you stated
so I'm thinking you know why would he
get up there and just insult you well he
wants his friends to hear him he wants
to go home and high five them
my concern is does that convince people
because I I have I have a concern about
the future of this country if there are
voters convinced by what that guy did
first of all it was funny when he got up
and said I'm a mathematician and a
physicist so I know I'm right and then
talks about mental health and biology
while criticizing you for not being a
biologist when neither is he which you
pointed out
I suppose my my greater concern is are
we wasting our time
trying to have logical arguments with
people who are not interested in logical
arguments um I mean yeah yes I mean the
argument wasn't with him but the
argument is on behalf of the audience
and I think that this is where the media
coverage really gets ugly because the
truth is that for the people in the room
who may not have been decided who showed
up or who watched it online who may not
have really had an opinion on the issue
if they just watched that entire clip
they're going to come away with I think
what any sane person would which is this
person really didn't have an argument
and that I was making a large number of
arguments citing data citing recent
studies and all the rest and they would
come away with that impression the way
the media coverage comes off is it's
just Rock'em sock'em robots and this is
by the way how you end up with pretty
much the worst of every aspect of
politics and it bleeds up right this is
why when you get to presidential debates
you'll see that it turns into basically
something that looks like the seventh
grade sort of playground School flight
just people shouting names at each other
and there's no way to fight that there
really is not because what am I supposed
really what am I supposed to say to that
if somebody gets up and they insult my
wife right or if somebody gets up there
and they insult my sex life or something
how am I supposed to come back at that
as a sort of rational and polite human
being the answer is you can't and if you
go low then you're the person who's
really the bad guy so it's a lose-lose
it's the reason why you know not all
these debates are worth it but I agree
my uh I think it's a lose or lose no
matter what however the way I typically
respond is I don't understand why you're
being so mean to me
uh so I I've actually you know I've
gotten in Facebook arguments and I'll
always try to approach it reasonably
calmly rationally and if they they
immediately come back and say something
nasty I just say I'm sorry I don't
understand why you're being so mean to
me right now and that's just my Approach
but in the end it doesn't matter because
what's what's really happening on stage
here is
the audience who agrees with a rational
discussion of the ideas and real answers
is looking for those and the people who
just want to hate because they're driven
by emotion just want to see you be
insulted so whatever you say doesn't
matter to them that's right tell us why
you have to be super careful in in terms
of who you actually engage with so the
the nice thing about going to college is
that you do get you know a lot of people
from the other side of the aisle who
engage some of them in really good faith
and that's that's awesome when that
happens whenever I do these these
question lines I always say if you
disagree you go to the front of the line
that's the standing rule but it's also
why when when I decide you know who I'm
going to talk to on the show I tend to
try to talk to people who I think on any
side of the political aisle are actually
going to have an honest conversation so
for example I had on my Show rokana
recently the California Congress version
row is really far to the left and we had
like this really good conversation about
minimum wage he's going to come on the
show again I've had Andrew Yang on the
program we've done Universal basic
income by anybody who's willing to have
like a good long-form discussion is
great the problem is that the way that
everything is framed and the way that
everybody is sort of exposed to this
material is you
Ben Shapiro debates acts well if you
actually watch the conversations it's
usually not a debate usually it's a
discussion and somebody kind of comes up
short in the discussion so it's not a
debate where some even the bench Patrol
destroys videos are typically not
something where I'm being like an
[ __ ] to somebody it really is much
more I make an argument the other person
doesn't have like a very good comeback
and that's sort of the end of the
conversation but good example was the
bench um the bench bear was was Ben was
you on uh Bill Maher with Malcolm Nance
yeah and I'm watching that and I'm I you
know I'm I'm listening then Malcolm
Nance just immediately goes for the
emotional attack yeah I mean that was
kind of shocking to me honestly uh I
mean I was trying to be as polite as I
could be I really try to be polite in
all these scenarios and I I was
complimenting him I was saying listen
your Former Intelligence analyst like
you know that this is true and and there
came a point where he just started being
incredibly insulting on on the show and
there's not much that you can do with
that frankly and like when you say oh
well I can't believe anybody listens to
your show well I mean first of all you
know you never want to make the ego play
this is a lesson that I've learned
before right I've been in situations
like just as a human being one of the
lessons you learn uh as you know you get
more notorious uh is that making the ego
play is almost invariably a mistake
you'll be in a situation and you'll be
like I'm bigger than this person I'm
more people listen to me than this
person it ends badly for you that's what
happened on that famous BBC interview
right no idea who's interviewing me and
so I'm like I have no idea who you are
and of course it turns out the guy's
pretty famous in Britain I'm just not
from Britain uh so it's it's so you can
make that mistake you know that is that
if when when if someone came to me and
said I don't even know people watch our
show I'd just be like I agree
honestly I just you know the way I
describe it is like I don't know I I
complain on the internet to a camera but
apparently people you know like watching
it so I'll always just be like dude if
you want to be the mean person in the
room that's fine because I don't know
how he convinced people who's whose
intention is just to be mean to
emotionally destroy other people I'm
looking for solutions that kids seem to
be like disappointed that he said what
dsm-4 and you were talking about the
DSM-5 and so he was humiliated and
lashed out out and if you can say it
seems like you're humiliated because
you're wrong about the dsm-4 thing
usually puts them in their place also it
it's kind of you just got to take the
humility when you do that like being on
stage and being a performer let people
Rock You in life everybody see about
your mouth you know everybody's seen
your your debates discussions when
you're wrong you say you're wrong yeah I
tried to I mean I think I'm one of the
only public figures in America where I
have like a running list on our website
of all the stupid and dumb things I've
ever said in my entire career like going
all the way I mean I've been writing
columns syndicated column since I was 17
years old I'm now 30 age I've been doing
this for over two decades and most of
the dumb crap that I said was in the
first I would say quarter of my career
like from the time I was 17 to the time
that I was maybe 23 24. and so I have a
whole running list of like every bad
tweet that I think that's bad and I'll
say like that was a bad tweet that was
stupid here's why I did it here's why I
was wrong I I you know I you try to be a
reflective human beings I think part of
being a good human being is trying to be
reflective but when you're a public
figure you also have to balance that out
with the fact there are a lot of people
who just want you to be destroyed and so
how do you take criticism you you have
to have a filter system where people in
good faith can come to you and say you
did this wrong and you really think
about it but then there are a lot of
people who are just you know going on
stage and calling you bozo and that's
not a good faith criticism and so at
that point you just kind of have to be
done I'll give you I'll give you an
example on our end we we've never done
for Tim cast IRL any digital debates or
any conversations
because they just they're not that good
you know I went on Sunday special with
you and it was it's kind of stunted in
that you'll talk then I gotta kind of
wait because it's we're not in the same
room
so there was a point where I tweeted out
we've we've tried to book big left
personalities because the door is always
open we want these conversations vosh
who many people don't like has accepted
on more than one occasion with a smile
on his face and he's had a lot of really
creepy things that a lot of people call
him out for and don't they're mad at us
for platforming but I'm like look bring
them on have him say it then we'll we'll
challenge him and he's tried deflecting
from these things but there are a few
personalities I'll leave their names out
of it who publicly accept him I will
come on your show name the time and date
and I say here's the time and date we
will pay for your tickets we'll fly you
out first class we'll get you a hotel
just let us know and they go you got it
then they DM me privately and say I'm
not coming on your show yeah it's all
for show so we've got one individual who
is just one of the worst you know most
bad faith individuals I won't even
there's no open door for this guy but uh
you know just uh recently Hassan this is
the funniest thing you know you know
Hassan he's a left personality
David Pacman tweeted he owns a mansion
right yeah he's mostly wouldn't know
about him yeah he's like most good
socialist he has a Dasha in the woods
it's nice
you can't participate in the society
to participate yeah that's great I mean
he needs to be comfortable I think it
seems a lot but uh he tweeted in David
Pacman tweeted is anybody actually
pro-abortion I've heard this but I've
not seen anybody actually say it Hassan
responded me I Am David said is anyone
trying to increase the number of
abortions Hassan said me I am trying to
do this it it it look it was
tongue-in-cheek and I felt it was
obvious of course he doesn't literally
want to challenge David Pacman and give
ammunition but David responded with
sounds weird someone then responded with
what's wrong with more abortions so I
screen grabbed that interaction I said
nothing and I tweeted it I thought it
was funny that Hassan appeared to be
trying to snark David David didn't seem
to realize and then someone actually
agreed with this with the true premise
not thinking he was a joke Hassan
assumed that I took him seriously and
then started disparaging me on Twitter
so I said he said I pretend to be a true
Progressive or that me and Dave Rubin
and I are are influential to people who
claim to be true progressives and I I
said I never said I was a progressive I
I'm not a progressive I say I'm a
moderate with some left policies
he responds with you're doing exactly
what I'm making fun of you for my
immediate response is
you have an open invite invite to come
on the show and say anything you want
unimpeded and the immediate reaction is
everyone saying for one excuse or
another we won't do it we can't do it
I'm not gonna do it the first excuse he
gave before was oh covid so we can't he
publicly said I will come on your show
then privately says oh no covet I can't
do it this is the difficulty with trying
to engage with these individuals because
I don't think they actually care about
solution or or logic based uh solutions
to our problems I feel like
they do what they accuse us of doing
emotional Arguments for the sake of
making money and I'm like if that's the
case why is it that Ben Shapiro is the
debate me guy who's trying as hard as he
can to have you come and explain all of
your ideas and I'm sitting here saying I
will literally pay for you and first
class five-star hotel so you can tell us
your ideas but it's constantly that side
that says we won't do it yep and I think
that they they also play this game where
they act as though if you would like to
have a conversation they get determined
in the form out of the conversation the
format of the conversation does matter
an awful lot I mean as you point out
there's a big difference between having
somebody in person for something that
you do versus doing something via Zoom
this actually is a pretty large scale
thing it makes a big difference in terms
of are you having a conversation or are
you having a debate if it's a debate is
it something where there's a moderator
or is there non-moder is going to be
time or is it not gonna be time because
you actually prepare for these things
differently so for me when I'm preparing
for an actual debate then I actually do
research into the person I'm debating I
try to look at everything that they've
said I try to see how they approach an
argument so that I know exactly what I'm
facing I treat it like you would a prize
fight because you sort of have to go in
with that mentality and then sometimes
you know it gets it gets pugnacious and
sometimes it doesn't but you have to
treat it like that but you have to know
the format going in and what I find very
often is that there's a lot of
sandbagging that goes on and I I really
try not to sandbag people when I have
people on my show and I say it's just
going to be a conversation it really is
just a conversation I try to give them
space to to expand on what on what
they're saying and when I say it's a
debate it should be like a formal debate
where there's an actual timer here with
somebody with a clock and there's a
moderator and somebody asking questions
but but failing to distinguish between
the two is one way of preventing those
good conversations from happening it's
something I also see in the comedic
world I mean there's this whole school
of thought and mostly existing in the
comedic left where it's the clown knows
on clown knows off routine and it's
really obnoxious it's the reason why
I've said I won't do you know I've been
invited on Trevor Noah before and I've
said I won't do it unless it's live I'm
not going to do it tapes because I know
that you guys cut this stuff and I'm not
going to be humiliated by the cuts that
you make around a comedian whose job it
is to just make funny faces in the
camera he's going to be better at that
than I am I'm never going to be as good
at that as he is if he wants to have
like a political conversation we can do
that in long form if he wants to just
sit there and make faces at the camera
he's going to win I mean there's no way
I can win because he's a comedian so you
know the terms man the other thing too
is with uh
if we're gonna have a real discussion
some a lot of people well I'll just
point out again not saying certain names
but they'll they do ambushes they they
lie they'll say yeah I'll have a
conversation with you let's do zoom and
then it's somebody else or they've got a
chat going giving them answers and
helping them because they're not
actually prepared for these real
conversations I have no problem with
that you know some people have said
they're going to get help from the
audience and I'm like let the audience
help them all the issue is when I have
conversations I've had a I did a
conversation with David Pacman uh before
and some other individuals and the left
calls them all debates and I was like I
never agreed to I don't debate people
because I don't think I have all the
answers I'll ask questions I'll tell him
what I think I'll say oh I didn't know
that but they're acting like we're all
going in to just fight each other yeah
that's what I'm wondering how important
is it how invested percentage on one to
100 do you think you should be in your
argument when you're taking on an
argument so you know I think that it
depends on how much you know about the
topic really so there are certain topics
where I just don't know all that much
and so I'm not particularly invested in
the argument when it comes to you know
drugs uh I I literally I've never tried
them I don't know that much about them
you know this is not something where I
feel I'm an expert in the subject so
when I'm on Joe Rogan and he's talking
about legalization marijuana I'm like
well he knows way more about this than I
do so I'm just going to let it go right
or DMT well he does way more
um but and and this is true on a lot of
topics if however I'm really deeply
invested in a topic and I really feel
like I've studied it and then I'll stick
to the arguments but the one thing that
that I I won't do is pretend that I know
something that I don't so you'll see
pretty frequently that you know in these
you know scenarios these debater
discussion scenarios if somebody
mentions a study and I don't know the
study I'll just say I don't know that
study I'm happy to take a look at that
study I'll assume that what you're
saying is true assuming what you're
saying is true and then I'll ask a
question but you know that's just being
in this space for a long time one of the
things that you learn again it goes back
to sort of the the ego problem if you
say that you know something that you
don't you're going to get caught with
your parents down that's just the way
it's going to work do you find that if
you're really emotionally invested in
something that it's easier for someone
to twist you twist your ego in an
argument yes I mean absolutely that's
why the hardest thing is where somebody
you know says something about your wife
or something right and that's that's
that's very difficult so you have to
like take a breath and just kind of you
know calm down that's that's the whole
goal I mean that's really why people try
to throw you off your game by by doing
that sort of stuff and it's also why
there are certain topics I frankly don't
enjoy debating very much because I I'm I
feel like I have to make a conscious
effort to separate myself off enough
emotionally from the topic that I can
have a good back and forth conversation
without getting angry or upset and
that's where the good conversations
happen do you remember the uh reality
has a liberal bias that that statement I
think it was Stephen Colbert who said it
was it Colbert yeah was it because he
was pretending to be a conservative time
you know I I think about this and it's
fascinating because I grew up watching
Jon Stewart I watched Colbert uh I
watched Bill Maher and um today I would
say reality has a conservative bias it's
not so much that it's conservative
values but for whatever reason
they uh the reason why I'm called
conservative has more to do with what I
what I view as true and correct as
opposed to What policies I align with or
whether I'm more Progressive or
traditional so I can I can come out and
be like actually you know I lean
slightly left on a lot of these issues
but more Libertarians so it's a very
difficult position to maintain to be
completely honest it's hard but um Joe
Biden is crooked he did illicit business
deals in Ukraine you're conservative
Tulsi gabbard can come out and say she
wants gun control she wants to ban
nuclear power and that it was wrong to
to strike Syria with missiles she's a
Putin asset she's right-wing she's
conservative so when I hear someone like
Hassan friends and say Tim Poole you're
a right winger and you know it I'm like
that doesn't mean anything dude because
I know right winger is just what news do
you believe
but the issue I see with this that makes
it very difficult uh for me looking at
the state of this country and moving
forward is
how many stories have to come out that
are proven false before any one of these
people is just going to be like okay
maybe I should listen to Ben Shapiro or
Tim pool or Sheamus or Ian and hear what
they have to say about these ideas
because I've insulted them and now it
turns out that story I believed was
false and it's not even just about
listening to us it's just about not
listening to CNN anymore I don't know
like you said I don't know how many
things they have to get wrong before
people are willing to say okay I'm not
necessarily going to move over to the
right but maybe I should stop getting
information from people with a
repeatedly lied to me B never apologize
for lying to me and C never faced any
consequences when they did it it depends
on their emotional state if they're calm
it usually only requires a little bit of
logic
um people are erratic it's it's a lot
more it comes into a point near
impossibility nearly everything in
America and a large part of this is
social media has become a social litmus
test right you're expected it's not that
you're expected to believe that men can
become women and women can be man you're
you're expected to say it and you're
expected to say it publicly and this is
a litmus test as to whether you're a
good person or not and so the question
is do you want to be accepted in the
proper Social Circles if you're
accepting the proper Social Circles this
means that you think the temple is bad
or you think that he's a right winger or
you think that Ben Shapiro is a rabid
right winger who's intolerant with other
people's opinions or I mean like these
are things that you are expected to say
and believe if you wish to be accepted
in certain Social Circles this is like I
I think that the best way the the the
pronouns test is there for a reason the
reason that people are putting their
pronouns in their Twitter profiles is
not because people have doubts about 98
of the population whether they identify
as male or female because again 98 of
the population identifies either male or
female but it's there when a clearly
male person puts he him in his profile
that's there to say I'm part of your
group I'm part of your in-group and I
wish to be accepted in your in-group
because what other reason would there be
for that they say that it's all about
acceptance and making people feel
accepted it really isn't it's about
making them feel that they are accepted
it's about saying the thing that you're
supposed to say in order that everybody
treats you it was like this with Trump
too you couldn't just say you know I
here's here 10 Things I Hate About Trump
but I like that the Abraham Accords
happen if you said even I like that the
Abraham Accords happened people were
like no no no this means your pro-trump
because you've broken you violated the
taboo by saying that he is not evil and
satanic it was I think Nate silver no I
think it was Nate silver or it might
have been
um Ezra Klein one of the two said they
wouldn't even give Trump one good day
when he took out the leader of Isis yeah
just one thing we can all be like yeah
that dude was a monster and they were
like nope nope it was bad and that that
that's that's nauseating I mean I I want
things to improve but you know looking
at say like the uh the transgender issue
in schools which we can you know move
into a little bit
I grew up in a very Urban uh Urban
Democrat area
uh I went to public school I did go to
Catholic school for a little bit I went
to public school I never learned about
my teacher's sexuality I never learned
about their private lives in fact that
was like kind of Taboo in a public
school in the south side of Chicago uh
sixth seventh eighth grade and even high
school you didn't we didn't many of us
don't even know our teachers I can't I
can't tell you my teachers first names
and the only there's only one
circumstance where I learned about my
teacher's personal life her name changed
oh she got married and she had a picture
on her desk and one day we're leaving
and someone's like who's that she goes
to my husband and they were like oh and
they're like let's go kids and that that
was that was the end of it now there's
some kind of you know I bring this up
because
I grew up in Chicago everybody knows
they always bring it up like oh Tim says
it a lot yeah but I grew up in you know
a city that's been controlled by
democrats right now what is it 100 years
and I don't think it's normal what
they're trying to claim these teachers
are doing to kids it seems like a new
phenomenon it seems like it crosses a
line and the Wall Street Journal uh
wrote an uh the editorial board wrote
about this poll that came out showing
that even among Democrats I think it's
59 of Democrats support Florida's
parental rights and education bill I
don't know where where they expect to go
with this politically but clearly
something is wrong in these schools that
goes beyond left or right but I suppose
to wrap this together your right wing if
you just say hey maybe strangers
shouldn't talk to my kids about this
that's a conservative position I guess
yeah I mean I've never seen anything
quite as politically inept as trying to
turn parents into a voting Block it's an
unbelievable thing I mean there's 63.1
million people in the United States who
have a kid in their house under the age
of 18. and you're turning those people
into a massive voter block which has
never happened really before in American
life that's like security moms in 2000
0004 that wasn't the same thing it
wasn't like we are actively targeting
parents and saying that parents aren't
doctor getting their kids we have to
counter indoctrinate their kids so that
we can make sure that these are tolerant
and diverse little people who accept and
approve of our of our ways of life if
you're seeking approval from a child
you're doing it all wrong I mean the
entire idea of being a parent I have
three kids the entirety of being a
parent is the kids are small monsters
and then you civilize them over the
world yes I mean they really they're
very cute they're very innocent and
they're also monsters right they're like
the worst people ever who are also
incredibly cute and wonderful they
demand things from you all the time they
have no sense of propriety they have no
sense of logic and your job is to
civilize them and to make them better
people over the course of time instead
because as a society are a bunch of
adults who are acting like children and
they expect the children to validate
their points of of you I mean what
you're saying is is entirely correct I
went to school in Los Angeles I was in
public school for I would say about half
of my educations I was in public school
for elementary and then part of middle
school and same thing I mean I don't
remember learning about the private
lives of my teachers I'm sure I had
teachers who are gay there's no one in
particular I'm sure was was a gay man
and that never came up in class because
why would it and by the way if if he had
put a picture of him and his husband on
his desk and then somebody had asked
about it then the proper response would
be you should go talk to your parents
about this is a controversial social
issue go home talk to your parents about
it it really isn't my place to say I'm a
social studies teacher I'm a history
teacher I'm a math teacher why is this I
have no idea why any of this is remotely
controversial except that the left
believes that they have to cram down
their point of view on everyone and so
if you're gonna be imperialistic about
my kids you can't expect me to sit there
and just take that I think it has a lot
to do with that um when it comes to the
birth rate conservatives have more kids
liberals don't and this means in 20
years conservatives are going to keep
gaining more political power while the
left loses it but you know I wanted to
ask you when you were growing up you
were religious we became fully religious
time about 11. so I remember eating at
KFC yeah okay yeah so do you think that
helped helped you like you know I read a
bit about your backstory you skipped
several grades you seem to have worked
very very hard you played instrument
what do you think it is about you that
led you to be successful
so I I think that I mean obviously you
know I'm
thank God I I'm pretty smart guy I was
able to skip third and Ninth um so I
graduated high school when I was 16
graduated UCLA 20 graduate Harvard Law
23. um but I think that one of the best
lessons I ever learned is I was I was
coming from so I was in public school
until I was in fourth grade then I went
to private school for a couple of grades
and then I was back in public school
when I went to public school the public
school I went to was was a magnet and
you had to take an IQ test to get into
the magnet it was the highly gifted
program at Walter Reed uh and uh and so
they gave you a basic IQ test and you
had to get above a certain score which
is pretty high in order to get in I got
in but not by like a ton I got him by
some I was in this class with kids who
had 180 190 IQs there was a there's a
girl in our class who was doing like
engineering level calculus in maybe
seventh grade and just Geniuses Geniuses
and the thing that I noticed is that it
what my what my dad said to me is listen
in most rooms that you walk into in
virtually every room just assume when
you walk into a room you're not going to
be the smartest guy in the room but you
can be the hardest working guy in the
room and so that turned out to be a very
good lesson I look back at it the people
I went to Walter read with and I don't
know how many of them are successful I
don't know many have many of them have
built things one of the things that that
happens when we are very smart I think
is that you tend to think that things
are going to come easily to you and it's
very easy to fall into this pattern of
taking things for granted for me that
was really never an issue I I work
incredibly hard I've worked incredibly
hard for a very long time uh you know
every spare moment my staff can tell you
basically every spare moment I'm I'm
reading I'm writing like literally all
the time uh and uh and so it I attribute
it yes some to thank God some some gifts
but but a lot of it is just keeping your
nose to the grindstone I I had some
moments you know that
maybe I made some realizations I'm at
Occupy Wall Street
I show up and I'm a high school dropout
nobody knows my name I got a camera what
do these activists say to me they said
man you're the perfect example of what's
wrong with this country you know you're
smart you're hard working but look you
come from a mixed race background and
you come from the south side of Chicago
it proves there's something wrong with
this country where good smart people
should be succeeding and they're not and
then a month later I got featured in
Time magazine for my hard work and they
said he's a white kid who was born with
a silver spoon but that's that verbatim
is what they started saying is her
posting saying whoa yeah white privilege
all of a sudden my family history all of
the stuff I had talked to them about in
agreement with on I wouldn't call it
left in politics at this point I'd say
populism like hey the the financial
crash was was led to a whole bunch of
faulty spending corrupt deals
all of that's erased all that matters is
if you're successful you can't be a part
of what it is we're doing so we're going
to attack this is exactly right I mean
they retcon people's past on a routine
basis so I mean for for me if you search
about my background online what you'll
see is that I grew up people on left
side all the time I grew up in a wealthy
home that is not true okay like I'm not
I I never think by the way that if you
were born poor and then you made it this
makes you more better morally than
somebody who who was born rich I know
people who are born poor who are jerks
and people are born rich or jerks and
that there's you know all that money
does is make you more of who you are so
if you're if you're a nice person you
make a lot of money you tend to be nicer
because you have a lot of money and you
can spend the money and if you're a
juror can you make a lot of money you're
even more of a jerk because now you've
been liberated to be a German um but but
you know I grew up in a in a two-bedroom
home 1100 square feet in Burbank
California with three sisters until the
time I was 11 I shared a bedroom with
all three of my siblings right it was my
parents in one bedroom and us in the
other bedroom and one bathroom for six
people and that that's not like
impoverished that's just that was a nice
middle class up I would say maybe lower
to middle class upbringing in in Burbank
California and it was a great life and
it was fine you know why because I had
the ultimate privilege which I had two
committed parents who were there for me
making sure that we were working hard
every day and making sure that we were
taken care of and that's the only
privilege that I think really matters in
American life is what the stats show by
the way also you got two parents and the
parents are there and they're taking
care of you you are the privilege you
you won the lottery you were born
America and you won another Lottery
which is you have parents who give a
[ __ ] about you that sounds a lot like
you know that's the privileged argument
you literally called it privilege it is
a privilege I mean the issue is that the
left skews the idea of privilege into
things that are somewhat meaningless
well things that don't require anything
of them right because if I acknowledge
that there's some sort of privilege and
being from a two-parent home that I'm
now taking upon myself for moral
obligation to ensure that if I do have
children that I stay with the person who
I have that child with so that I'm not
depriving them of their potential but
they don't want to control themselves
sexually so they'll never acknowledge
that what was it like when you were 11
you mentioned it twice already that you
became religious and you said did you
move out of your yeah so when you become
religious in the Orthodox Community what
that means that you have to move within
walking distance of the synagogue so so
that was coincidence it right so when
you become Orthodox we've been living
not in walking distance for the
synagogue we would drive our car to the
near the Orthodox synagogue and then
you're not supposed to drive so we'd
Park about a mile away and then we'd
walk so as not to you know make people
feel uncomfortable like we were that we
were driving to synagogue essentially uh
and then we moved into a neighborhood
where we were within a walking radius of
a synagogue but yeah it was you know it
it didn't I thought it was honestly I
thought it was great I love living in
the Orthodox Community I think Community
is massively important I think it's the
main thing that's been lost in American
life I think the nationalization of
media has has destroyed a lot of the
feeling of local community the the ties
that I have with my neighbors in the
community where I live it's one of the
most important things in my life is one
of the most important things for my kids
and I'm very fearful of of the
destruction of local institutions on
behalf of national and international
institutions that are seeking to
dissolve those societal bonds that
actually matter the most the stuff you
care about is the stuff with your
neighbors not the stuff you know that
you do on Facebook with some [ __ ] about
how much time do you think you have left
I don't want to keep you too long we've
been going about half an hour uh a
couple more minutes maybe so I want to
give Ian a chance to ask you about
climate change uh because in that in one
of the viral videos I saw of you
speaking you said these these uh climate
change stats and predictions don't take
it into a consideration mitigation
factors Ian is obsessed with graphene
yeah are you familiar with it I'm not
going pure carbon it's a hexagonally
lattice carbon we should pull it up um
carbon dioxide to graphene and you'll
find it's so they've been it's basically
gonna be like the 21st century steel
it's a building material you can make
touch screen wallpaper to Super
conductor super capacitor uh can be
lightweight you can you can you know mix
it with lots of different materials too
and make all sorts of crazy Alloys and
things so you can deposit it from carbon
dioxide and you talked about mitigating
factors with climate change and how
scientific models tend to project
without assuming that anything is going
to change right I I totally agree I made
a YouTube video about this a couple
months ago and I want to point out I
don't know if this you consider some
mitigating Factor there's an adaptation
it's an adaptation that's the other
phrase you use adaptative Technologies
well I want to point you at this you you
said a little while ago that we're going
to be competing with trees for carbon
dioxide if we do it wrong if we think
ahead and we build the system so that
we're taking just enough carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere and producing just
enough to keep the trees healthy then
we'll be living in symbiosis but if
we're Reckless we may end up that's
really cool I mean the one thing that I
think about human beings and this is
what I said in that little kind of
snippet is that we are very good at
adaptation and very bad at controlling
ourselves so basically when forced to by
circumstance necessity being the mother
of invention we will make moves to
preserve our own lives right we will we
will if if they cut if the tides start
to rise we will move if the if the
temperature starts to get warmer we'll
figure out air conditioning right that
we've been doing this for a very very
long time and human beings are there's a
reason why we who do not have claws and
are less muscular than other species
why we have adapted to the point where
there are seven eight billion of us on
the planet and the reason is because
thank God our prefrontal cortexes are
very well structured for adapting to
circumstance we are we are tools we are
we are active we're not just a tool
making creature we ourselves are like a
jackknife of evolution this is not me
saying it's like Brett Brett Weinstein
and Heather and his wife Heather higher
uh um I always mix up Heather Hein and
Heather higher because the names are
similar but um whichever is the one
who's the scientists yeah uh so yeah so
Heather hying they're a tremendous book
about this and basically what they say
is that human beings are a jackknife and
that that's right we are a jackknife and
what that means is as things get worse
in one area we're able to adapt and
we're able to to change and all of these
scientific models that basically say
hundreds of millions will die you're
assuming that basically people who are
living on the coast in Florida today are
going to be living on that exact same
Coastline in 100 years I'll tell you how
we know that everybody is going to adapt
the reason we know this is because all
the same liberals who are deeply
concerned about global warming are
buying Coastal real estate for tens of
millions of dollars if they really
thought that in 20 30 years all that
stuff was going to be underwater why
would they be spent I mean that's one of
the memes that they use about me online
right I said that if you think that
you're that your house is going to be
underwater you're going to you're going
to sell it and people's like who are you
going to sell it to well the answer is
apparently a bunch of left-wing Liberals
are buying all of the quotes from Real
Estate for 30 million dollars but let me
uh Ben I got this for you real quick
what we're looking at right here is
Martha's Vineyard as you may know Barack
Obama purchased a I believe it was a 12
million dollar property in Martha's
Vineyard just near the uh Edgar Town
Great Pond the address is publicly
available we're not going to show the
address let me show you what happens
when we use the noaa.gov website to
raise uh the water level by two feet
okay we've got a flood plain now in
these areas and this means you can see
that the the water level is starting to
rise and erase some of the the ground it
is already affecting Barack Obama's
property two feet only let's go three
feet okay now about you know maybe 10 to
15 of his property is gone four feet all
right now about 30 to 40 percent uh five
feet more I would say about 70 to 80 of
his property is gone at six feet all
that's left is the building at seven
feet his property is completely wiped
out at eight feet and Beyond there is
nothing of Obama's property left wow the
previous owner's hand so that be safe
yeah the issue is as you mentioned I'm
looking into this and I'm like I think
there's issues if humans just you know
drive off a cliff and we we don't take
care of ourselves but you mentioned it's
going to take a thousand years for 200
feet of water this is what they've said
in a thousand years 200 feet of water
and I'm like do you think in a thousand
years humans just keep doing the exact
same thing without changing maybe they
just just plant their feet in in cements
and they just stay right there is the
water level gradually rises above their
nose it's it's really dumb the answer is
that human beings are going to do what
we've always done which is why New
Orleans is still there right so after
the levees broke after Katrina and it
flooded New Orleans and 10 000 people
died they rebuilt all of the levees and
they short up the levees and last year
there was a massive hurricane that went
directly through the same area and
pretty much nobody died because it turns
out that they didn't build the levees
crappy this time so what was that that
was a good adaptation that preserved the
lives of the people living in that
floodplain now let's say that they had
been unable to rebuild those levies do
you think those people would have been
staying in New Orleans they would have
picked up and they would have moved many
of those people did pick up and move
after Hurricane Katrina figuring that
they needed to move out of that area so
again human beings are great at
adaptation this is true financially also
you can always bet that human beings are
going to solve a problem after it
materializes we're not very good at for
seeing a problem and trying to avoid it
but once the problem materializes we're
pretty good at reacting to it just
evolutionarily I wish we had more time
with you is there any final thoughts or
anything else anything you wanted to
yeah Sheamus do Ben Shapiro's voice with
Ben for a second
he does it better
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then I had to do my Jordan Peterson
impression in front of Jordan Peterson
it's not always a comfortable experience
I would be embarrassed to do it when
when you when you reacted to his video
where he did the impression and then he
reacted to you reacting that was that
was really beautiful you reacted to a
cartoon I did of you and then I did a
cartoon of cartoon you reacting
it's an infinite regression I love it
yeah right on man uh yo thanks for
hanging out it's been a blast thanks for
letting me come by absolutely man uh
thank you uh thanks to the Daily wire
for letting us crash in your uh yeah and
before I leave I just have to have to
ask you how do I subscribe to that
chicken feed how do I make that happen
you just go to chicken City on YouTube
youtube.com
my kids will be into the chickens yes
and pets and everybody and I'll I'll
wrap up with one final thought on this
because it's it's weirdly people on the
left are insulting me over a live stream
of chickens it's it's meant to be the
hokiest wholesome family friendly thing
that's not political calm they're angry
they're saying look how stupid these
people are and I'm just like if you're
not having fun you're doing something
wrong I mean if you're mad about
chickens I don't know how we have an
argument well they insult you for
selling emergency food when they think
the world's gonna end right
change so I don't know it's true there's
no there's no appeasing him Ben did you
want to shout anything out or mention
anything before we wrap up I can go
check out all of our work over at
dailywire.com and check out my podcast
the Ben Shapiro show anywhere you get
podcasts or you can follow me on Twitter
where I'm trending every three weeks
yeah all right man thanks for hanging
out and for everybody else thanks for
hanging out and uh stay tuned for
another uh interview with Jonathan Isaac
right now we are hanging out for a
special interview with Jonathan Isaac
who is an NBA star who refused to kneel
for black lives matter he's publishing a
book called why I stand and I'm just
reading about this I am so impressed by
by your willingness to stand up for what
you believe in and the CR there's so
much crazy stuff about this story first
and foremost I'll tell you why I get
fired up seeing your story Jonathan
because a lot of people refuse to stand
up even when deep down they deeply
believe something and that's all you got
to do is everybody just stood up for
what they believed in things would be
better so here's your story where
everyone around you is kneeling for the
national anthem which is crazy to me
because it's the national anthem every
every uh sporting event we have
everybody you know they they sing the
song special guests come out and sing it
how do we get to this point where all of
a sudden you're supposed to be kneeling
during this and that you standing up
where you believe in which is
essentially like a long-standing
American tradition becomes this profound
statement I just I I am impressed by
your willingness to defy the crowd
because of what you know is right so
let's let's just jump into your store I
suppose of course we also have Ian he's
hanging out as well hi everyone and uh I
want to learn your story man so so tell
me what's going on yeah so first off
just thank you so much for having me on
I'm a fan of everything that you guys
are doing
um so I would say to kind of just wrap
it up in a hole in a in a whole thing of
what how it all makes sense
um so around the time of the whole black
lives matter thing George Floyd
um is as tragic as it was and as you
know awful as it was goes down
um and then there's this there's the
whole
play of black lives matter everywhere
everyone is is pledging their allegiance
to Black lives matter um the
organization and early on in the process
I I never felt comfortable standing in
that Arena you know I'm I'm a Christian
um I feel that Christ is ultimately the
answer for the world's problems that's
me that's what I've I've grown up on and
what I've come to truly believe later in
my life here is now and I never felt
comfortable professing that in the black
lives matter space
um and so as everything got kind of just
worked up we get to the NBA bubble and
there's the pressure that everyone is
going to take this stand they're going
to kneel and they're going to wear a
black lives matter t-shirt and I have
made the decision that that's that's not
what I want to do um I don't believe in
it I didn't believe that the black lives
matter spirit in terms of what they were
ultimately trying to do went hand in
hand with where I was in my heart
um and I I decided not to so obviously
it was super crazy
um uh a bunch of you know people feeling
the way that they felt about me deciding
to stand came out and it just if we get
to the point we are now about writing
this book about the story of why I stood
the backstory of who Jonathan Isaac is
what is going on in his life to get to
this point of standing and offering that
as the the remedy to the situation we
found ourselves in now isn't it crazy
that it was uh you know several years
ago Colin Kaepernick he kneels
and and he gets criticism for it and
we're in this moment we're like oh you
can't do that now it's inverted now
everybody's kneeling and you're standing
up like I'm not gonna kneel for this and
now there's a story behind standing up
and refusing to bend with the crowd it's
it's it's it's interesting in how this
trend quickly swept across Sports and
and to that point when Colin Kaepernick
did kneel the the NBA itself you know we
had a team meeting we had everything and
they said you're not allowed to kneel
it's it's we're not going for it we're
not gonna kneel it's not what we're
doing and even though they didn't the
teams didn't come out and say it's
something that you're absolutely not
allowed to do it was absolutely the
sentiment of like we're not doing that
we're going to focus on basketball we're
going to play that was the sentiment
especially in our team meeting and then
to have it flip you know two years later
and everybody like we have no choice and
that was ultimately my issue part of my
issue where it the feeling was you
either did this and if you did it you
agreed um you you stood with black lives
you cared about black people and if you
didn't you were an enemy and you were
evil didn't care and the sentiment was
wearing a t-shirt and kneeling for the
national anthem do not go hand in hand
with supporting black lives it's not the
only way to support black lives because
when I look at my life my life has been
supported by Christ and and that's the
message that I that I wrote on so so
tell me uh a little your quick life
story I guess how you came to be in the
NBA what was it like growing up for you
so uh I grew up in Bronx New York
um family was super Christian we were in
church all all the time my dad was was
super into it
um I got into basketball when I left New
York and moved to Florida my parents had
split up there I started playing you
know organized basketball AAU
um started falling in love with the game
really finding my identity in the game
getting getting uh getting liked getting
cared about
um having people gravitate around me
because of basketball so I started to
really just fall in love with it and
worked extremely extremely hard at it
went to Florida state for a year got
drafted and ended up in Orlando
so when you were growing up how would
you describe your experience and I'm
asking you from the context of black
lives matter right so so you're a young
black kid growing up in the Bronx
playing basketball and we hear this
narrative from BLM that this country is
racist white privilege all that stuff
considering that you didn't take a knee
for it I'm curious as to your thoughts
based on your life experience about the
general narrative from black lives
matter not the underlying politics which
we know gets deeper but yeah so I would
say there's two parts to that I would
say growing up in New York it was
definitely something that we were taught
about you know as as kids you know
there's certain things that you want to
watch out for you want to make sure
you're respectable to police you want to
uh make sure you're not out here causing
any trouble but my family household was
definitely I would say unspokenly on on
a conservative Trend in terms of work
really hard compete in the workplace
compete in what you're doing become the
best that you can be and ultimately that
God is going to take care of the rest if
you trust in God you're going to get to
exactly where you need to be where
you're supposed to be and there's not an
outside pressure that take away from
that there's there's not something that
trumps God being in your life and
ultimately guiding you into where you're
supposed to be and then um when it comes
to Black lives matter it's the sentiment
that the only problem when it comes to
Black inequality is racism and that's
ultimately not ultimately but a part of
what I would say I reject so I don't
know if you guys have seen I'm sure you
guys have the the Jordan Peterson uh
interview with uh what was her name I
just had her name in my head uh Kathy
Newman Kathy Newman all right right and
what he's trying to get across to her is
that it's the notion that sexism is the
only reason why there's inequality in in
Pay between women and men and does it
account for something yes but is it
everything no and I would say the strand
of the black lives matter is to teach
you or to get you to believe that racism
is the only reason for inequality
between Black and Whites they actually
it's a I think Eber Max candy he says
it's not a question of did racism happen
it's how did racism manifest that's to
say that is to say in any circumstance
there's always racism present and to me
that's that that that's a crazy thought
but it also forces people
I I think what it ends up doing this
narrative that we see from critical race
Theory and black lives matter is you're
basically telling people success is out
of your reach right due to things you
can't control
but that's just not true
you can succeed if you work hard I I you
know and and I think you're an example
of that yeah for sure like you know
putting in the work to become an NBA
basketball player grinding every day and
just almost the work being in my hands
it being my job and my duty to go out
there and work to become um who I want
to be and I even want to say
and oh the overarching theme in the book
is love it's saying that as I've become
the man that I am today and growing in
the love that God has for me and walking
that out I'm believing that if we could
truly love each other black white and
different
um over our uh deficiencies or what we
do wrong the destructiveness of both
sides we could get ahead and so the book
is saying that because of I'm going to
show you how Christ's love has been
manifested in my life and I believe that
that love is going to be what really
changes the world for the better what's
the book called why I stand
when did you finish writing it uh We've
we finished writing it uh shoot that's
that's a good question I would say at
towards the uh what month is it it now
uh April I would say towards the
beginning of uh this year so around
December January how long did you spend
right now about a year wow I can't write
a book man I don't know how people do it
yeah did you have other people helping
you write it I had another person helped
me write it Amy um she's fantastic she
helped me write it but just we had time
so a part of the you know kind of the
blessing in disguise from the injury is
that I had down time to just focus on my
rehab and and work through this book
what was the injury I tore my ACL oh
yeah I think I had an MCO there at some
point you told me earlier you got
injured and I was like oh okay well
we'll hear about that an ACL tear yeah
was that on the side of the knee or
something right right in the middle
right in the middle I've been
skateboarding my whole life and the ACL
tear is the the dreaded injury it's
definitely a lot different than what it
used to be in terms of oh yeah obviously
back then in the day you hear ACL and
it's like oh my gosh it's the most
dreaded thing but you know where we are
today you know you get about a year and
some change and you're good you got like
the PRP injections uh platelet-rich
plasma we didn't do that but um you know
the the whole thing is it's it's good
now we're pretty much ready to roll into
next season so it's it's Colin
Kaepernick experience is a big backlash
when he takes a knee I'm wondering if
now that the narrative's kind of
inverted and you're the only one you
know standing up basically are you
getting Flack from other players are you
getting Anger from activists are they
mad at you uh I I would say yeah it's
it's definitely a part of it um there's
a little part in the book where I talk
about directly after I show
and there was a there was a whole team
meeting that I that I got kind of pulled
into and it was about me and my decision
to stand and and and that I was
hijacking The Narrative of what you know
they were trying to accomplish and and
ultimately what the sentiment was there
for me is that I respected your decision
to kneel
um when we had that team meeting and we
said this is what we're gonna do I
didn't say well why the heck are you
guys doing that give me give me your
reason and everything like that but
that's all that I wanted in return so we
were able to walk away from that meeting
so if you consider yourself conservative
right wing I would I would consider
myself I I've tried my best to allow my
Christianity to God my principles and
ultimately what it is that I believe
um I believe in in the love of Christ I
believe in obviously the defendants of
the Bible and what it teaches and I
think that it's definitely caused me to
to to to lean on the conservative side
on those a lot of those different issues
but I wouldn't come out right saying I'm
conservative I'm Republican it to me it
kind of feels like we're seeing a lot
more intolerance from the the left I
guess as you'd call it however you want
to Define it in that
they you know there you say I respect
your decision to kneel you know do your
thing they get mad at you for not doing
it right and and we see similar things
in a lot of different facets we often
see uh I mean in terms of guns in blue
states where I understand they got high
gun crime and they want to try and solve
that okay fine but then why do you want
to law over red states where it's Rural
and very different it seems like there's
constantly enough you know you got to
live this way you got to do what we want
to do
and it used to be when I was younger at
least the perspective was that the right
was more like that more moral
authoritarian now it's kind of flipped
and I'm sitting here talking to people
at the daily wire more conservatives who
are very much like I disagree with you
but pursue your happiness do your thing
yeah absolutely absolutely I think
there's definitely a trend on the left
that is like we are so tolerant we are
we're not authoritarian but it it really
is the complete opposite where um
we are we want you to be tolerant
towards us but we don't have to be
tolerant towards you and so that's
definitely the strain that's coming out
of the left and you're not telling
people they got to stand or anything
like that you're just doing your thing
you're staying true to yourself
absolutely it was it was projected to be
a symbol it was projected to be nearly
us kneeling and wearing this t-shirt
we're symbolizing support for black
lives but when it's a symbol everybody
doesn't have to go along with their
symbol once it becomes you have to do
this then it's no longer a symbol in my
opinion it's a command and that is what
I was rejecting so so by standing was
this was this more statement in support
of the Pledge or was it just a statement
not in support of black lives matter I
would I would say both definitely not in
support of black lives matter but at the
same time I love the country that I live
in
um the the one of the things that we're
taught in church all the time is that
you haven't done everything right but
you haven't done everything wrong either
in terms of striving to be better and I
think that that's a sentiment that's
lost when it comes to America I love to
live in America the freedoms that we
we've been granted and obviously
everything has hasn't been done right in
terms of the history but everything
hasn't been done wrong either in terms
of taking the steps to for us to help
progress and get to where we are today
yeah when it comes to terms of like
racism and systemic racism with BLM and
things like that I I think we talk a lot
about this actually on the show um the
history of like slave slavery in the
United States was like an African slave
trade so the people that came over
happened to have that skin color but it
was just those were the slaves that were
brought they could have been from
Ireland they could have been from you
know wherever uh Middle East or whatever
but so the ancestors of those people
it's like a class issue like the great
grandfathers of slave or the great
grandchildren of slaves the family
wealth that's passed down is is there's
not a lot of wealth passed down because
or or education maybe isn't passed down
because a lot of times your parents will
be the ones that teach you when you're
young and so it's misrepresented as a
racial issue when it's more of like a
class issue that happens to be those
people from that place and and so to say
that it's the skin color that causes it
just drives me insane I don't know if
you agree with that I would say say it's
both I think it's definitely a class
issue but especially when you get into
the Jim Crow era and that it definitely
became a much about the skin color of
like black versus white and hating
Blackness
um in in a sense for sure so I would I
would say it's both I would say as it is
today in terms of definitely the the
tone of hating Blackness has has
decreased and now it has definitely
become more of a class issue and if
we're able to kind of break down those
barriers of Education
um to me getting back to God in the
first place we can see a a huge increase
and that's that's also in the different
you know people that are dark skinned
that are over in America today the West
Indians the Nigerians that come over and
do really really well if we could adopt
some of those family principles
education principles along with like I
said for me the biggest point is getting
back to Christ in the first place you
know I think we could see much more
progress than we've seen when other than
beating the racism horse I completely
agree with how you how you put it I
think when you look at the past there is
absolutely racism it was it was
absolutely somebody would look at
someone see what the color of their skin
and immediately just be like I have a
problem with that today there's there's
elements of that absolutely people are
racist but I always tell people at this
point it's it's a class issue I do think
in my review on this and maybe I'm wrong
but because of the historical racism
that we saw with slavery through Jim
Crow and all that you've got less
generational wealth that's passed down
right which results in a pronounced
class issue today but we've passed a
bunch of these laws to make all of the
race-based stuff illegal what scares me
is I feel like we made a tremendous
tremendous amount of progress from the
60s and the 70s and the 80s not perfect
but we've done a tremendously a great
job it is illegal to discriminate the
basis of race and say housing or
whatever school but now we're actually
seeing there was an article I saw um
earlier about a woman a white
Progressive liberal woman saying
segregated classrooms are a good thing
and I'm like that that kind of sounds
like going backwards and that's part of
the problem like I want people all to
hang out together and be comfortable
hanging out with each other and being
happy with each other her argument was
white people have white only Spaces by
default default because there's so many
white people they'll go into a room and
it's only white people and that's not
fair to black people so there should be
spaces that don't allow white people and
I'm like no I mean like I I get it if
it's a private thing and you want to
hang out and do whatever you want sure
that the clan can have their rallies
whatever I don't like that like I'm not
gonna hang out with those people but in
public institutions and public
accommodation I actually enjoy being
with people from various backgrounds I
don't understand how they're the ones
claiming they're arguing for diversity
while simultaneously trying to put
forward these things that create like
POC and non POC spaces did you see the
it's hilarious the video I don't know
who put it out some some comedian but
he's pretty much conflating the
similarities between the racist and the
woke
in front of ours yeah and and and the
sentiment of that is even even take the
the Justice uh the Lady Justice that
just got nominated uh
katanji Brown is like with this with
this Narrative of it's impossible to get
ahead it's impossible to be black and
have opportunities and stuff here you
have someone you may not agree with
their ideology or anything somebody who
has ascended to the highest court it's
like it it doesn't make sense it doesn't
complain and if racism was such an issue
it didn't Prevail in that case well I
mean look at the Thurgood Marshall for
instance I believe he was the first uh
black Supreme Court Justice and this was
back what the 60s I think yeah then you
have you have Clarence uh uh Thomas and
the funny thing is they put up these
articles they were like katanji brown
Jackson as the first black Supreme Court
Justice and I'm like Clarence Thomas is
still alive he's still here and and you
get Bill Maher Bill Maher said
Republicans would be happy with no black
supreme court justices and the funniest
thing is this Republican guy got a viral
tweet he said literally the black one is
the only one I like I saw it yeah that's
the only one I I I I it frustrates me
seeing
how the left is I I I I think many of
these politicians many of these
personalities not all of them I think
they're scared to give up racism because
it empowers them to go to people and say
you are constrained by this problem and
only I can solve your problems gives
them power over other people yeah I
don't like the victimization tactic
that's what I feel like black black
lives matter is doing maybe not even
intentionally maybe it's intentional or
not but saying that because of the way
you look you're gonna have a harder time
like I don't think that it's it's the
skin color that's causing it like there
there might be reasons why people but
like you said if you try hard doesn't
matter what your skin looks like your
eyeballs are telling the story I well I
think
I I have I have no problem actually I
don't know if you said that I said that
I don't know if you said I don't put
words in your mouth I got a problem if
there's a uh anyone of any race and they
say the United States is a majority
white country and that means there's
going to be assumptions made about you
that means some people might be racist
but if you work hard enough if you work
smart enough and you figure out how this
system works you can be the richest
person on the planet you can be
successful you can be famous that will
not be you know race I mean
any factor of your born with your height
Mugsy Bose for instance bugs am I
pronouncing around yeah you're right
that dude I am he's an inspiration my
whole life because when I heard uh what
was he 5'3 yeah and he could 360 dunk he
could jump higher than his own height
and I'm like you see they this is a guy
there's so many people who are like I
can't do this because of this thing and
it's like man maybe maybe there's some
limitations you know maybe you're not
going to be tall enough to play but
there are people who defy those odds and
say I will do whatever it takes I will
work hard and overcome any any of these
these these presumptions that's what I
want to know what was your work ethic
like when you got to Florida and you
started playing ball and you realized
I'm gonna do this for a living I I just
fell in love with it if basketball
really became a love for me and so it
was all I did I woke up and I went to
the course and I played from sun up to
sundown every day all the time got with
friends organized let's play here let's
play here and it just it just it just
became I just got better but there
wasn't even a thought of anything
outside of that there wasn't there
wasn't fear of not there wasn't fear of
some somebody stopping me from making it
it was just that I love this game and
I'm gonna play it and I honestly just
got passed along from one stage to the
to the next and and here I am in the NBA
not everybody can be in the NBA yeah
true it might be like like Ben Shapiro I
don't think it's gonna happen for him
you know you never know but yeah so but
but that's the reality of life too is
that as much as some people might say oh
there's some physical disadvantage you
have it's holding you back well
sometimes you have advantages too right
the way I view life is we're all we're
all doubt this hand of this hand of
cards and yo I've seen people win poker
hands with the worst possible hand
because they they knew how to play it
right how much of it do you think is
physical gifts that get you in the NBA
versus work ethic
I would say it's it's a lot of things in
a whole it's it's absolutely if you if
you average out NBA players we are a
specific build we are a specific height
across the board
um and in that same group of guys you
also have probably the most the hardest
working guys who have kind of risen to
the top in their different fields and or
different positions and stuff in
different places in the country and
their physicality goes in that as well
but then there's another piece in terms
of just mentality being able to block
out the noise being able to block out
the distractions being able to focus in
on this one thing really hard to attack
the NBA is a culmination of all those
different things in guys that are
different heights come from different
places they're usually the hardest
working guys with the best attributes
and the best mentality that have got
them to that place do you think other
players you know so you're standing I
see this photo of these other guys
kneeling do they all support black lives
matter
I would say no I would say
um and I would say that because of the
sentiment when we had that conversation
about what it is that we're going to do
in terms of are we going to kneel are we
going to stand it wasn't it wasn't that
everyone was saying man I I care so much
about this issue and I'm so in line with
the black lives matter movement that I
want to kneel that that was definitely
the sentiment from a couple guys but the
rest of them was that we don't have a
choice it was that either you do this or
you do not care about black people the
first question that I got asked after I
stood in the press conference was do you
even believe that black lives matter and
I'm like and I'm like and I'm thinking
of my head like wait you're a part of
the problem you're part of the problem
because in your mind you're conflating a
T-shirt and kneeling for the national
anthem with the very care for black
lives and to me that's it they don't go
together what was the who asked you that
I don't remember the reporters like it
was some probably some white woman I
imagine no
she wasn't white but it was a woman but
I'm pretty sure she was a black woman
but it was just the first question out
of the gate you didn't kneel you didn't
wear a t-shirt do you even care how
crazy this is this blows my mind you're
black exactly to ask somebody that like
Candace Owens they say that she's a uh
they tell us that only white people can
be racist then they tell us Candace
Owens is a white supremacist and I'm
just like I just I don't want to hear it
man I wanna I you know I want to hang
out with people I think people are cool
people I don't think race is it
determines whether someone's cool or not
I think some people are cool and some
people are bad people there's bad white
people bad Mexican people bad Asian
people bad black people there's good
black people there's good Asians there's
just because people are all different
types
I just what really really bugs me about
the whole thing we've seen in the past
several years of the rise of critical
race theory is the hyper focus on race
and you know specifically in this
example if you don't take an action in
support of a brand of a non-profit it's
a it's a it's a a statement about your
morals as pertaining to a racial group
of people
and and that's exactly and that's that's
exactly what it was where because of the
name because of the name black lives
matter you forget that it is in support
of an organization and organizations
have ethos they have ideologies and now
you have the same organization going and
buying you know a six million dollar
house so it's like when you when you
when something as tragic as a George
Floyd happens and they're able to put
out this this this phrase or their
slogan that says black lives matter it's
like how could you not jump on board in
this of course black lives matter of
course this was a of course this was a a
a a terrible moment in time of of of a
black man being killed cops racist or
not it was awful
um
but every Everybody agrees with that so
it's like you you distance yourself from
the from the from the the organization
and just come through with the with the
phrase that everybody agrees with and
that was ultimately I'm thinking about
the organization I'm thinking about what
the organization stands for I'm thinking
about that the organization is against
God and against family and against all
these different things that's not
something that I can support they are
they they had on their website
disrupting the nuclear family that to me
you know I I personally believe in God
uh I I was Catholic a little bit growing
up but I'm I would I don't consider
myself religious like theistic I just
believe that there there's a God is the
simplest way to explain it but I also
recognize the importance of some kind of
faith for people and without that they
turn to tribalist critical race Theory
they try and find purpose somewhere and
they get this weird facsimile of it I
also think that family is extremely
important I had I had I had two parents
I grew up in a house with two loving
parents who who you know helped me
become a better person and I think
that's a major advantage so when I see
black lives matter say disrupt the
nuclear family when I see these articles
written by feminists who say if feminism
is too is to succeed we must you know
end monogamy or the family or something
like that I'm like yeah that's gonna be
really really bad for kids it's it's
it's a political statement made by a
non-profit Corporation basically like
what you're saying if you really want to
help black people and black lives and
you're in a room with thousands of
people and I got all this I'm not if I'm
not trying to give money just to the
black people it's going to cause
resentment amongst all the other people
and then it's gonna disprove it's gonna
make it worse for those people that I
gave the money to because they're going
to become like hated by the others you
want to improve everybody's life well
this together and then it improves black
lives and what and everybody can rise up
but I do understand the systemic class
problem that we're having let me look
from the slavery issue let me elaborate
on on that because what I think was
happening now you know we we had serious
racism in this country for a long time
even up to the 80s are you familiar with
blockbusting and redlining redlining not
so much blockbusting blockbusting is
dark stuff man so what would happen is
Real Estate Company would go to a white
neighborhood buy a house and then move a
black family in they would then go door
to door to the white families and say oh
look who just moved in your property
value is going to go down now you better
sell to us before it's too late they
would it's it's it's it's crazy that
they would they would do this and then
the white people would get scared and
they'd start selling their houses and
then once the real estate company bought
up a bunch of the houses they would say
thank you to the black family your lease
is up you can leave now and then sell
all the houses back at the profit they
would use racism and the fear of racism
to rip people off and it was destructive
to the black families it was destructive
to these these white families that was
that was happening up until the 80s
that stuff it's it's dark stuff and
redlining too
now some people try to argue oh no it
was all a victim of of Market forces and
I'm like
yo we know people did this like their
stories it was in the 80s it was
happening but here's my here's my point
where I'm trying to get to it with your
point
we made that illegal you can't do that
anymore you can try there may still be
remnants of it you can try it's illegal
and people will come after you you'll
get sued so this means now that we've
said by law like we don't want this to
happen anymore
you've got poor white people on the
south side of Chicago living alongside
poor black people all of a sudden
Democrat comes along and says we're
going to give all the black people money
and the the poor you know white person
is sitting there wondering like why am I
starving
me and my neighbor are both people
but he's been given money and I'm not
I think the issue is we've dealt with it
policy wise there's still I think some
policy you know things that we could
probably accomplish we've not solved
every problem in the world
but I think it's a class issue today
that is solved if if the issue is that
black communities in this country are
disproportionately impacted by
historical racism then it would be true
today that a class-based solution would
disproportionately benefit black
families and that should be that should
make the left and the right happy
because not a race-based issue anymore
there may be you know out of uh you know
nine families in one block that are
black families that are impoverished
there's one that's white or whatever the
number might be but everybody gets an
opportunity to be lifted up and be
helped out for some reason the modern
left is not okay with that you know in
California they tried repealing the
provision from their constitution that
prohibited racial discrimination in in
college and public Contracting and I
just think that's that's them walking us
backwards who's going to bring the
problems of racism back how deep do you
go into it in the book
in terms of well the history of
basically history from slavery to now
the history of racism and classism you
know honestly not so much the the the
book is mainly about again about about
the love of Christ it's about taking
every taking where we're at and
ultimately all the problems that we have
that are not just racism just just just
world problems in a whole but saying
that if if each of us could find the
answer in love loving loving our
neighbor
um loving someone who has done wrong to
us loving someone who who we don't like
or anything like that we would
ultimately see progress before all of
these other things come into play and
it's it's an interpersonal answer of one
of affecting one person then affecting a
family then affecting a city then
affecting a society and ultimately the
world do you know who Daryl Davis is no
he's this uh black jazz musician one day
he went to a clan rally and he said he
said he thought to himself how could
this person hate me if they never met me
so he shows up and people are they're a
bunch of racist but he starts talking to
them
in his in his time I think he's been
doing this for a couple decades he's
de-radicalized like 200 clan members
they've taken their robes off they say I
was totally wrong about being racist he
didn't do it by starting a movement
waving flags he didn't do it by going on
TV and making demands of government he
did it by going to an individual person
and saying hey I'm Daryl nice to meet
you and he tells these stories one of
these stories is amazing he's got he's
hanging out with this like high-ranking
Clan member and then he turns out this
clan member is a huge rock and roll fan
well Daryl's Blues musician's got
connections and he's like oh yeah that
famous Cadillac you really like yeah I
know the guys who have it you want to
take a ride in it you want you or you
want to sit down and check it out and
he's like oh are you kidding me it's a
dream come true and it's like come with
me man and then this guy's like all of
these things they told me about race and
racism was not true
Daryl's a a great guy who's a good
friend of mine just by being friends
talking to these people he made them not
racist right that's the Amazing Story
and and taking him to that car and
letting him running it that that would
be in my opinion an action of love an
action of extending an arm across the
aisle that's saying I don't believe all
of this other stuff that people are
saying I want to get to know you I want
to know who you are and extending that
love and if you get it in return amazing
if you don't you keep on loving and I
believe that that is the it's the
message that has helped get us to this
point in terms of Martin Luther King
about you overcome evil with good and
love ultimately and and not fighting
back in the way that is riots and these
other things but ultimately finding it
in your heart to love your neighbor
because you've Been Loved by God I
believe is going to be the how we
progress I saw a tweet from a prominent
atheist personality I'll just leave it
at that and he said that he's tired of
playing on defense he says every Bible
must be sold with a warning label that
it says it may lead to mental
derangement
and that and that's crazy to me because
here we are having a conversation every
conversation I've had with uh um any
prominent religious person obviously not
every person is a good person no matter
what the religion is is a similar
message to what you're saying love your
neighbor and and try and be your best
you know our good friend Sheamus with on
the show is very very devout Catholic
there's a lot of things he he does not
agree with and he thinks are wrong but
he he doesn't force himself upon people
he doesn't attack people he doesn't
insult them he well we all insult people
you know especially when we do comedy
but he doesn't attack people and and
scream and he's not vile he's he's like
I want you to do better with your life
and I wish you would do better how I
wonder how it is that
you know the narrative from the left
perhaps because they want to do away
with Christianity they want to attack it
at its core they they keep pushing these
lines about what Christians believe but
then you actually sit down with any
prominent religious individual
and they're talking about love and
forgiveness and trying to to reach
across the aisle and things like that
I'd agree with you in terms of it being
about Christianity and is ultimately the
one to attack you don't you don't hear
much about attacking other religions
even you know is Islam or anything like
that it really is the Christian ethic of
love and ultimately
um the morality of it um that's that
gets attacked because the left wants to
do away with all of that and just live
in a in a state of what feels right for
you why do you think that is
I believe because Christianity is true I
I truly believe that that is the it's
it's it's it's the relationship with God
that is based on God loving us in our
sin um and and working our way to us and
not us working our way to him
um and it being and the Crux of it being
about love um I believe is the reason
why that it gets it gets attacked in the
way that it is and because even if if
you go through it the people who do
attack it know that it's true and it's
ultimately the one that you have to
contend with and it is the religion of
the West and ultimately if you're going
to take down the West you're going to
have to take down Christianity you know
one thing I often bring up on the show
is that this culture where we're
experiencing I think has a lot to do
with
two different moral Frameworks there is
the judeo-christian moral framework
which I think everybody in this room
agrees with but then there is the
Marxist or fascistic moral framework
I I had a conversation with a uh there
was a family coming around my
neighborhood in the in the New Jersey in
South Jersey Philly area and they were
uh
preaching they were they were or what is
it called when they're evangelizing
evangelize income with the Bible and I
had a good conversation where I pointed
out that
I don't I don't I don't believe I'm not
I'm not theistic you know I go to mass
or anything like that I do believe in
God but I also recognize the lessons
from the Bible that we hold true today
that our core principles in our country
such as
uh the presumption of innocence if you
are accused of a crime we are supposed
to presume you are innocent until it is
proven Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and
that tenet comes from the Bible the
story of Sodom and Gomorrah that uh a
lot you know God said if there's but one
righteous person I will not destroy
these cities and it was only after the
righteous people were all saved from the
cities that God you know he reigned
firing brims on around Sodom and
Gomorrah but the the point is I was
reading about the Fifth Amendment how
powerful it is in protecting the
innocent this country is far from
perfect but it's pretty good I've been
to a lot of places
and it said the founding fathers had you
know Benjamin Franklin it is better that
a hundred guilty persons Go free than
one innocent person suffer and I said
wow a hundred that's huge because
Blackstone he was this British judge I
think where uh he said it's better that
10 guilty persons Escape than one
innocent suffer and I said where did he
come up with that I agree I like that
idea he talks about how
if your society would punish the
innocent then people would have no faith
in your society and if if they're uh so
so inclined upon just punishing someone
for doing something you'll actually let
the bad people go free you need to make
sure you have a very high standard for
whether or not you're going to imprison
somebody or punish them or or seek
retribution or Justice uh because if
you're if you're getting the wrong
people the bad guys are getting away
with it and the good guys are hurting
everybody's mad but that idea came from
the Bible and often uh law is not good
so in times of evil law you need to let
the criminals Go free because they're
the good people like in Nazi you know
you can claim all right
exactly that's the crazy that's crazy
but so you know in thinking about this
I see people like Bill Maher he's like a
secular atheist but he doesn't
understand when he believes in free
speech when he believes in the right
presumption of innocence these are
founded in Christian Moral Moral values
now we have the rise of this wokeness
and things like BLM they don't believe
in that framework they hate it they want
to destroy it they abide by typically
the ethos of there is no truth but Power
where they think that if we get enough
people to say it it will just be true
and that's all that matters I'm a big
fan of uh take care of yourself before
you attempt to take care of your
neighbor the take a take the plank out
of your own eye before you attempt to
take this Speck of dust out of your
neighbors or something like that do you
have a I think that's incredibly
valuable now Jordan Peterson talks about
cleaning your room take care of yourself
right now now is the time do you have a
favorite tenet in Christianity well I'll
just I'll just start off by saying to
your point about how much of the
judeo-christian ethic is baked into
everything in the west and it's almost
like to to to to attack it is to is to
vary attack the foundations of society
itself
um maybe on purpose maybe on purpose for
sure but I say probably my uh my
favorite attendant is you you do unto
others how you would want to be what you
would want to be done into yourself and
um
I think that it speaks to it speaks to
the very Crux of a human being in terms
of the way you want to be treated the
way you want to see things happen in
your own life you give that to someone
else and ultimately you'll create a
society that wants to be lived in and I
think that idea is rooted in the belief
there's something outside of you there's
something bigger than you that another
person exists they have inalienable
rights the same as I do when you
understand that you try to do better by
other people to the best of your
abilities but then I look at a lot of
what's happening with black lives matter
and this activism is very narcissistic
individuals who are going to smash up a
window or set fire to a building or hurt
someone because they don't care about
what they're doing to others they don't
believe what you just said because I you
know for a fact that these people who
are smashing Windows would freak out and
be angry if someone smashed their window
they don't want their Windows switched
it's almost like they don't care about
what exists outside of them
right and and and to the point is that I
believe that those people can be reached
with love so it's it's almost as if the
the people who or who are out there to
me who are who have been who have been
manipulated by media manipulated by uh
whoever's at the top that is trying to
get these things done manipulated by the
black lives matter organization that
those people if shown in love can
in a sense be redeemed in a sense of
because we've been redeemed ourselves
but ultimately that those people are not
evil those people are not terrible
people they're in a they're in a
predicament of again being manipulated
by the powers that be and ultimately
take the klansman for example that
person
you could say from the jump that he
never hated black people but he's been
manipulated by the ideology but because
there was a black person that was
willing to reach his hand across the
aisle he could wake up and see that
there's a better way and see that he can
ultimately love or like whatever a black
person I you know I'm a little a little
bit more pessimistic but I ultimately
agree with you
in in the story about the clan there's
another really crazy story in that we
booked Daryl Davis to speak at an event
in in the south in the south in the
Philly suburbs South Jersey
and
far left activists threatened to burn
the theater down so the theater kicked
us out without question we ended up
having to find a new venue the after
party was still in the same area and
these activists were outside protesting
and Daryl tried to go talk to them and
they wouldn't they screamed at him and
he said he never experienced anything
like it he said that he has gone to Clan
meetings and they've gone up smugly like
oh we know we're talking about we know
what you are but they still talk to him
when he tried walking up to antifa they
started screaming at him calling him a
fascist and a Nazi and he couldn't even
get a word in this is the argument we've
received on the show I feel very much
like you about communication and love
like I feel like if you allow someone to
understand you that they will become
living in a place of love it comes it
just happens right but that the argument
we're getting is that these people this
black lives matter these leftists or
whatever are feel like they're at War
mentally and when you're at war with
someone
you may want to love them but they're
still going to kill you because you're
at War uh and if you can get one of
those soldiers over to your side and
then you're able to talk to them they
will convert but during the war love is
not the tactic and I don't know if
that's true but this is the argument
that I've been getting I I think it's
fair to say and we'll uh you know we'll
wrap up with a couple thoughts here
there have been many people who are on
that side who have have come around and
been like wow I was wrong to think these
things there's many people um we've
talked to people like Carrie Smith who
used to be a woke Progressive activist
on the left and now she's Christian uh
I'm pretty sure she's a Christian right
she is yeah yeah and I think Candace
Owens herself even was on the left you
know some time ago and then people start
to break through they start to get
access to information I think a lot of
what we hear about uh Christians and
maybe this is what's one that's always
benefited me is that going to Catholic
School
when I see these narratives from the
media about how Christians are
manipulative mentally deranged or just
mean or nasty or Hypocrites I'm like
you're not talking about any of the
people I ever met or grew up with I
don't know like sure there was bad
people but people were just people I
think they're called they mean to use
the word Zealot not it doesn't really
matter what religion you're if you're a
zealot then you can become like kind of
hard to communicate with so uh we went a
little bit over but it's cool because
this has been fun uh Jonathan uh do you
want to tell people where they can get
the book how to get it head to Amazon
and just type in why I stand and
pre-order your book